Hello everyone and welcome to 3ABN Today
Bible Q&A. I'm going to be your host
today. My name is Ian Vanderval and I am
so happy that you could join us. We have
a full hour where we get to answer your
questions and thank you for sending them
in. But also, I want to just say a
special thank you for your prayers and
your financial support of this ministry.
Without you, we are unable to proclaim
this gospel to the world and to be able
to have programs like this to share what
everyone here at the table has been
learning. Uh because I know when you
answer or when you turn in these
questions and we have an opportunity to
answer them, we learn a lot here and
we're just grateful and blessed that we
are able to share it with you around the
world. So, thank you for joining us.
Thank you for for being a part of the
3ABN family. And what I'd like to do
right now is just take a few moments to
introduce who's going to be answering
your questions today. And then
afterwards, I'll tell you how you can
send in your questions. So across the
table here, we have Derell Thomas. Thank
you, Derell, for being here.
>> Thank you for having me. And it's always
a pleasure to join my brothers and
sisters on this program.
>> Amen. Amen. And to your left would be
Foutini. How you doing, Foutini?
>> I'm great. Thanks for asking. It's such
a blessing to be here. Thank you for
having me.
>> Amen. Amen. And for those of you who
don't know, uh she's still somewhat of a
newcomer. We had her here on not too
long ago and we were absolutely blessed
and the Lord blessed her answers as
well. But if you don't know, she
actually speaks and reads Greek
fluently. So, she gives us a very unique
insight to some of the questions that
she answers. And to her left is also
Pastor Denzy. Thank you for being here.
>> Thank you. It's a blessing to be here
and always enjoy studying and asking God
for his blessing to be able to answer
these questions.
>> Amen. Amen. And as promised, I want to
give you the ways that you could send in
your questions because I know we could
exhaust God's word time and time again
and it never ceases to amaze us how we
could just read something and it means
to mean something, you know, one day and
then we read it again and God opens up,
you know, some doors and explains more
of it to us. So, we know you have
questions and the way that you could
send them in very simply, you can text
them. Text them to 618-2283975.
Again, that number in case you're
listening on radio is 618-228-3975.
But if you are listening on the radio,
don't text and drive. And uh the other
way that you could do it is through
email, you can send it to bible qa3abnv.
Uh bibleqa3abn.tv.
And then lastly, if you are on social
media, if you're on Instagram, you can
go to 3ABN
official and you could send us a direct
message that way. And uh please continue
to send in your questions. We are more
than willing and happy to answer them.
And plus it helps us to learn and grow
as well. And we hope it does the same
for you. So before we continue though,
we want to invite the Lord's presence uh
into this um this study. So Pastor Dy,
if you wouldn't mind, would you have a
prayer for us?
>> Sure. Let's go to the Lord in prayer.
>> Our loving and wonderful heavenly
father, we are grateful to you because
of your mercy and your love for us. And
Lord, as we approach your throne of
grace, we ask for forgiveness of our
sins and cleansing from all
unrighteousness, we ask for the blessing
of your Holy Spirit, Lord, that we may
give answers from you to your children.
We pray, Lord, for all those that are
listening that you also will help them
to focus and also that you will help
them to understand the answers that you
have for them. And Lord, we pray that
you will help us to be encouraged to
know that you are willing to teach us
all. And we ask you for these blessings
in the holy and blessed name of Jesus.
Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. All right. Brother Derell,
I'm going to come to you first if that's
all right.
>> Sure. All right. So, we have a question
that came in from Randolph and he asks,
"Why was David's killing of Goliath
acceptable if God forbids murder? Was
David being used by God? Still, how is
this right?"
>> Okay. Uh, thank you, Randall, for your
question. And uh it's true that um the
Bible does say thou shalt not uh it does
say say thou thou shalt not kill. Um
other translations say um you shall not
murder. Um but the answer to your
question is actually found in your
question. Um consider a modern example
of a police officer who is being shot at
by an asalent in a crowded environment.
The asalant is not only endangering the
police officer who may have a family and
children um but also innocent
bystanders. And after pleading with the
asalent to stop shooting, the police
officer exercises his right to discharge
his firearm and to subdue the asalent.
This is by no means a condoning or
denial of the police officer's right to
use a firearm, but it's just to show an
example. And um if after police after
the police officer uh has opened fire,
the asalent continues to shoot and
refuses to stop and he is killed in the
interaction, we wouldn't say that the
police officer murdered the asalent. A
court would not charge the police
officer with any crime. Um what would
happen is maybe an investigation to
maybe critique uh the approach of the uh
police officer but in for all intents of
purposes the police officer may even be
honored or commended uh for putting his
life at risk. Uh so even in a merely
human sense uh in a judicial sense not
all deaths are deemed to be uh murder.
Um that's deaths that are inflicted by
someone upon another. Uh now let's take
that same principle and expand it a bit
uh in in reference to seeing how God
operates. So if we consider the story of
David uh where the Philistines uh were
encamped at the very borders of the land
of the Israelites that was given to them
by God himself.
What was the intent of the Philistines
while they were camped there? uh in the
book of uh 1st Samuel uh chapter 17:es 8
and n the Bible tells us that the
objective of the Philistines was
actually to enslave the people of God.
So now there were times when when the
people of God were permitted to be taken
into slavery by God uh because of
disobedience. But this is uh this was
not one of those those times. And so
when the Philistines and Goliath were
coming to take them captive, they were
actually not only contending against the
people of God, but they were contending
against God himself. We're told that
Goliath was um openly denying or openly
um opposing the God of heaven. And so in
this instance, when when David finally
made the decision to step onto the
battlefield against Goliath, he wasn't
just stepping out because it was on a
whim. It was God impressing upon him to
carry out divine judgment. So in this
case and in all cases when God would
send out people to kill, we know in the
promised land and they would go out to
um to defeat the enemies of God. In each
case it was God leading people, human
vessels to carry out his divine
purposes.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you. That was a really
tough question to answer. I appreciate
that. Thank you so much. All right,
Foutini, we're going to come to you. And
this question comes from a text uh or is
comes from a text from Jennifer in South
Carolina
>> and she asks, "Who is God talking to in
Genesis 1 26 when he says, "Let us make
man in our image?"
>> Yes, Jennifer. Well, indeed, the
declaration, "Let us make man in our
image," stands as a unique moment in the
creation narrative. So, let's go ahead
and see what God's word has to say. In
Genesis 5:1, we read, "This is the book
of the genealogy of Adam. In the day
that God created man, he made him in the
likeness of God." Now, this is speaking
of the genealogy from Adam to Noah. And
both in Genesis 1:26, where we find the
words, "Let us make man in our image,"
and Genesis 5:1, which we just read. The
Hebrew word for God is Elohim. And that
is an inherent plural noun, which
further supports a plurality of the
Godhead. But we're going to prove that
in God's word. There's another set of
well-known verses in John 1:es 1:3 which
read, "In the beginning was the word,
and the word was with God, and the word
was God. He was in the beginning with
God, and all things were made through
him, and without him nothing was made
that was made, and that includes the
creation of man." Now, here John is
speaking of the pre-existence of Jesus,
aka the word, in these verses. And we
know that because a couple of verses
down in John 1:14, we read, "And the
word became flesh and dwelt among us,
and we beheld his glory, the glory as of
the only begotten of the father, full of
grace and truth." Now, I'd like to
insert a lesser known verse, and that
would be in Job 33:4, where we read,
"The spirit of God has made me, and the
breath of the Almighty gives me life."
Now, there are two substantial
components in this sentence. First in
the Greek it reads
which literally translates to the spirit
of God created me which links that back
to the creation account. And then we
have the breath of the almighty giving
life which further links this text to
the creation account God breathing into
Adam's nostrils the breath of life. So
now let's go back to the very beginning
again because well yeah you can say that
that's what the verse means but what
does the actual creation account have to
declare about that in Genesis 1:2 we
read that in the beginning the the world
the earth was without form and void and
the spirit of God was hovering over the
face of the waters. Here we have the
biblical evidence that God the Father,
God the Son, and God's Holy Spirit were
present at the creation account and also
during the creation of man. But we also
see a God that exists within fellowship
and consults with all aspects of his
divinity when carrying out the purpose
of creating man. And he's created you
and me with that same capacity for
relationship. And although sin has
marred the image of God within us among
other things, there is a beautiful
promise that echoes all the way from
Genesis to Revelation that the same God
who says, "Let us make man in our image
still says, "Let me remake you."
>> Amen.
>> Beautiful. Beautiful. Thank you so much.
Very clear, too.
>> All right, Pastor Denzy, we're going to
go to you. And um this question comes
from Tracy in Idaho. She texts this in
and she asks, "Does God fulfill some
prophecies in ways we can't see or hear?
And is 1844 one of them?"
That's a very interesting question,
Tracy. I actually have never thought
about that, but it is kind of a
difficulty, I guess, for some people
because when you get to the 1844 date,
which we will talk about in a moment,
people don't necessarily see something
happening on the earth. But are there
prophecies that when it happens, you
can't hear or see? Now, there are
prophecies,
the purpose of prophecies for us to
really understand that God knows what
happens before it happens. But there are
some prophecies that people have seen.
Actually, let me rephrase that. People
have heard and have been waiting for,
but they didn't really see it in their
lifetime. But yet, for example, Genesis
3:15, "And I will put enmity between you
and the woman, and between your seed and
her seed. He shall bruise your head, and
you shall bruise his heel." Adam and Eve
heard God pronounce those words to the
serpent. The question, did they see this
happen? No. Actually, when you go to the
book of Hebrews, you see the great hall
of fame, let's call it, of people that
by faith did many things through the the
faith that and through the strength that
God gave them. And yet they did these
things and did not really see the
promise, this promise fulfilled. Let's
look at Hebrews 11:13. And it says,
"These all died in faith, not having
received the promises, but having seen
them aar off and were persuaded of them
and embraced them and confessed that
they were strangers and pilgrims on the
earth." So they did not see this. It was
about 4,000 years after these words were
pronounced that Jesus Christ came. So
these people died in faith. And so us,
we by faith must accept that the
prophecy that starts there in Daniel
8:14 concerning 1844. And for those
people that are new, I have to give a
little bit of a summary about this. In
Daniel 8:14, it says, "And he said to
me, for 2,000
days, then the sanctuary shall be
cleansed." Uh, this of course is a
prophecy. And when it talks about 2,300
days, these are prophetic days or
literal Yeah. prophetic days in which
one prophetic day equals one literal
year. So that's talking about 2,300
years. You have to read Daniel chapter
8, Daniel chapter 9 to understand that
there are several events that take
place. And you must read this. This is
your homework. You must read this to see
what events were take were to take place
that will help us to understand this
2,300year prophecy. So including the
appearance of the Messiah, Jesus Christ
being anointed, crucified, and then the
end of the 70 weeks mentioned or 490
years mentioned in Daniel chapter 9. So
we can have the benefit of looking back
and seeing that these things happened
exactly as they were prophesied. But it
is a matter of mathematics. We see the
beginning 457 BC and we just have to
count the years and understand that in
1844 Jesus Christ began the final phase
of his ministry as our high priest.
Question, do we see this? No, we don't
actually see it. But we know the date
tells us that Jesus began the final
phase of his ministry as our high priest
in the most holy place. So we must
accept this by faith. And just as those
that live before us did not see Jesus
Christ come, Jesus Christ die for us, by
faith they accepted it. And we that are
here know that Jesus Christ is doing
this wonderful work for us in heaven as
our high priest. we will see the benefit
like they will see the benefit of their
faith when Jesus returns and we all go
to heaven. Hopefully, this will help.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor Denzy. And
I like how you gave us a homework
assignment.
>> All right, Derell, I'm going to come to
you. Uh this is a text from Trudy. Uh
she's from New York. and she asks, "As a
Christian who is strongly against pork
eating, is it okay to prepare it for
someone else if I am require excuse me,
required to do so?" Uh, thank you Trudy
for your question. Uh, I actually am
someone who grew up for most of my life
eating pork. Um, and there are many
people today uh, and even throughout
Christian history who have believed that
when God prohibited the Israelites from
eating pork that it was merely to show
his authority. But today I am not one of
them who believes this. I believe
scripture is clear that it is not a
proper proper article of food for man.
And God never created the swine to be
eaten under any circumstances. And with
factors like the living conditions um
the fact that they will eat just about
anything including humans given uh the
right uh conditions and they carry
diseases and pathogens that can pass
from animals to humans. No wonder the
flesh of pigs is described like this in
Deuteronomy 14:8. It says, "Also, the
swine is unclean for you, because it has
cloven hooves, yet does not chew the
cud. You shall not eat their flesh or
touch their dead carcasses."
So based on the wording of your
question, it would appear that your
stance against eating pork is also not
mere preference, but instead a
deep-seated belief based on Bible truth.
So if we reword your question just a
bit, we come up with the question, is it
okay for any reason to violate my
conscience? Is it safe to go against my
convictions when they are based on
scripture? I'm sure that you would agree
that no matter what the situation that
it is not okay to violate our conscience
in the case of uh a request to prepare
food for a loved one or uh pork for a
loved one. I do not believe it is safe
to prepare anything that in your heart
you are so strongly against eating
yourself and then in the case of you or
someone else being a chef maybe and
being obligated to prepare pork or any
other unclean meat. I believe scripture
gives you right and freedom to walk away
from that position to guard your
conscience. Now someone might tell tell
you that violating your conscience is no
big deal. But listen to this. 1 Timothy
4:es 1 and 2 says, "Now the Holy Spirit
tells us clearly that in the last time
some will turn away from the the true
faith. They will follow deceptive
spirits and teachings that come from
demons. These people are hypocrites and
liars and their conscience is dead. So
what this tells us is that every single
professed follower of God is being
tested today to see if their faith will
lead them to violate their conscience so
that both their fa so so that both their
faith and conscience becomes dead. The
test is seeing if we are anchored in
truth or set a drift by our mere
feelings. My counsel to you echoes the
words of a beloved hymn saying be very
sure your anchor holds and grips the
solid rock and as the song says that
rock is Jesus.
>> Amen. Amen. Amen. You know I came from a
pork eating background too. So I
understand my family we all ate it. So
but there was something you brought up
that I didn't even think about even for
those who prepare. Yeah.
>> Um in you know a restaurant setting. I
didn't even think about that. So thank
you for bringing that up.
>> Sure. Uh, Foutini, we're going to come
to you. And this question comes from
Kathy in New York. She texts us in. She
asks, "Although studying the Bible is
essential, why is spending so much time
studying prophecy like Daniel and
Revelation so extremely important? I
mean, God's going to do what he's going
to do."
>> Sure. And he will.
>> Amen.
>> Praise the Lord for that. Uh, but in a
nutshell, let's look at what prophecy
is. In a nutshell, prophecy is the
foretelling of the future either by God
directly or by a person used by the Holy
Spirit. And this actually marries
beautifully with Pastor Johnny's
question previously with uh Genesis 3:15
being actually the first prophecy in
scripture. So, I know that you mentioned
Daniel in Revelation, but prophecy is
really depends on where you are in the
timeline because 3:15 was indeed a
prophecy for Adam and Eve. For us,
somewhat still getting there, but
overall, uh, we see that it doesn't just
pertain to end times, but I'd like to
dive deeper into the purpose of
prophecy. Considering the prophecy given
to Adam and Eve, we can see that it's
there to yes fortetell the future, but
also to provide hope that what you've
done or the consequences of sin will at
some point be no more because Jesus is
the victor.
And let's look at second Peter and find
a couple more purposes for prophecy. 2
Peter 1:6 reads, "For we did not follow
cunningly devised fables when we made
known to you the power and coming of our
Lord Jesus Christ, but were eyewitnesses
of his majesty." And then verse 19
reads, "And so we have the prophetic
word confirmed." Well, you have to know
it before you can confirm it. And so
that's where study comes in. It
continues on saying, "Which you do well
to heed as a light that shines in a dark
place." Well, why? Verse 21, for
prophecy never came by the will of man,
but holy men of God spake as they were
moved by the Holy Spirit. So here we see
prophecy also confirming and validating
God's word in a very practical way. But
the Bible also show shares a third
purpose for prophecy in Amos 3:7.
It reads, "Surely the Lord God does
nothing unless he reveals his secret to
his servant, the prophets." Now surely
one can infer here a warning or
edification but also we have that
opportunity for preparation not just
physical but spiritual. You have the
opportunity to brace yourself to fill
your mind and your heart with the word
of God to be prepared for what God is
going to do and to not be scared. But
the big deal here about studying
prophecy is that it doesn't end with us.
Because we can read in Acts 2:17, the
first part concerning the last days,
that it shall come to pass, says God,
that I will pour out my spirit on all
flesh, and your sons and daughters shall
prophesy.
Even though we know that the Holy Spirit
will bring those things to our
remembrance when we need them, well, it
can only bring it to remembrance if
we've put it there to begin with. If we
studied prophecy and particularly to the
end times is relevant to the book of
Daniel and the book of Revelation.
So we know that this cosmic disturbance
has begun and we can only know that from
our standpoint by studying the books of
Daniel and Revelation in conjunction
because we also read what is supposed to
come of that prophesying in Acts 2:21.
And it shall come to pass that whoever
calls on the name of the Lord shall be
saved. Well, how will they know? How
will whoever know to call on the name of
the Lord? How will they know to give
glory to God for the hour of his
judgment has come? How will they know
that Babylon is fallen? Or how will they
know of the mark of the beast? Because
the ne the heavens do not merely declare
the glory of God. Very soon they will
declare his judgment and his soon
coming. And so how will they know? Well,
we also read in Revelation that there
will be an end time people who keep the
commandments of God and have the faith
of Jesus and who also know that the
testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
prophecy.
>> Amen. Amen. That was beautifully
answered in a very short amount of time
as usual. So, thank you so much for
that. Um, I'm seeing, you know, kind of
a theme here with people wanting to know
more about prophecy and why we should
study. And I think it's really important
that we address these. Uh, Pastor Denzy,
we're going to come to you. This is from
Carol. She sent in this email and she
asks, "Can you please explain Jeremiah
3:16?" Thank you, Carol, for your
question. We appreciate you also pray
for us to answer these questions. So,
Jeremiah 3:16. I'm going to give you a
little context by starting in Jeremiah
3:14, and we will read until verse 17.
Return all backsliding children, says
the Lord, for I am married to you. I
will take you one from a city and two
from a family and I will bring you to
Zion. It's very interesting when you see
these phrases, one from a city, two from
a family. Like not all the family will
accept to come to the Lord. And that's
very interesting and it's also relevant
to us in these latter last days that
we're living in. Not everyone in the
family may be saved because some may
choose not to be saved. So we're talking
here about something that is relevant to
the last time to the time when uh we are
restored and redeemed by the Lord.
Notice and I will give you shepherds
according to my heart who will feed you
with knowledge and understanding. Then
it shall come to pass when you are
multiplied and increased in the land in
those days. And this is a key phrase
when you see especially in the Old
Testament that it says in those days or
in the latter days. It's talking about
when everything is over and God has
redeemed his people, these are the
things that that will happen. It says,
"In those days, says the Lord, that they
will say no more, the ark of the
covenant of the Lord, it shall not come
to mind, nor shall they remember it, nor
shall they visit it, nor shall it be
made anymore."
Verse 17. At that time
Jerusalem shall be called the throne of
the Lord, and all the nations shall be
gathered to it to the name of the Lord
to Jerusalem. No more shall they follow
the dictates of their evil hearts. So
this is really bringing us to a time of
the new Jerusalem. Heavens made new and
God is on his throne over all the world,
all the nations, over all the universe.
So the ark which was a symbol of the
presence of God no longer needed no
longer will even be necessary. It will
not come to mind. Why? Because we are in
the presence of the almighty God and we
can rejoice in knowing that we can come
to him anytime face to face we shall
behold him. What a joy joy that will be.
So this is really what Jeremiah 3:16 is
bringing to us. And so there's uh more
to this and uh we have to look at
context when we're looking at these
things. And sometimes God is making a
reference to things that are happening
upon the earth even for a time that
seems to resemble what it will be like
in heaven. But in this particular
instance, it is interesting that you see
the narrative and you see how it brings
to us the understanding that now all the
evil is behind us and God Almighty is
there with us.
>> Amen. Amen. I can't I can't wait for
that day when all that evil is truly
behind us and we can be with God face to
face. Looking forward to that. Um all
right. So actually we are about halfway
through. So, for any one of you that
who's just tuned in or maybe missed some
of the ways that you can send in your
questions because I want to encourage
you, send in your questions. We love
receiving them. We love answering them
and it helps us dive into God's word and
learn together. So, if you want to send
in your questions, you can do so by
texting us at 618-228-3975-618-228-3975.
You can also send us an email if you
prefer to do it that way. You can send
an email to bibleqa3abn.tv.
Again, that's bible qa3abn.tv.
And lastly, you can uh send us a direct
message through Instagram at
3abn_official.
All right, so I hope you get your
questions in soon. All right, so we're
going to go to you, Derell, and this is
from Taylor. And uh Taylor asks, "If you
ask God for something, receive it, lose
it, and then it returns, but you no
longer want it, what should you do?"
>> Uh Taylor, that's a a very good
question. Uh and sometimes uh we center
our identity in people and things and we
end up missing the mark of centering our
identity in Jesus Christ. You see, when
the thing prayed for goes missing for a
time and returns, it's easy to take it
to heart that if we have developed an
alternate identity outside of this
thing, then we are still okay with um
without it and thus we do not desire to
have it back uh in our lives. Now, in
the case where maybe the thing was
actually not an answer to prayer in the
first place, God can give wisdom uh as
for us to know how to avoid it the
second time. Uh but if the thing uh was
a person uh you had prayed about and
they went absent from your life that
makes it a bit trickier because let's
say that the person was an answer to
prayer that still does not mean that God
will force them to remain in your life.
They must make their own choices just um
as much as God chose them to be an
answer to your prayer. And
unfortunately, this is the nature of
life in a messed up world. You said that
you don't want the thing back in your
life after you learned to live without
it. Now, you could insert just about
anything into the blank of what the
thing or person is, but the answer to
your feelings is always found through
prayer. No one can prescribe for you who
or what should be allowed to be brought
back into your life after a period of
absence without any details. But God,
who knows your situation, is more than
able to discern what your response to
this thing or person potentially coming
back into your life should actually be.
With things like possessions, it's it
might be easier just to live without it.
But relationships are a whole another
ball game. Often relationships bring a
heavier weight of baggage. But thank God
that he is in a specialist in baggage
sorting. Now, assuming that your
original prayer was indeed answered by
God in the first place, something I
would encourage you to pray is this.
Lord, I believe you gave me this thing
or person in answer to prayer. As time
has passed, I have out of necessity
learned to live without it. Now that it
is shown up again, I am in desperate
need of wisdom and if necessary, a
forgiving heart.
I know that every outcome for every
situation in the lives of your
individual children is different. Help
me Lord to find my God outcome. I
believe that praying that prayer opens
us up to divine help and discernment. It
keeps us in step with the unfolding of
God's plan. God uh said once in Isaiah
55:8, "For my thoughts are not your
thoughts, neither are your ways my ways,
sayeth the Lord." But we can still rest
assured that God is not thinking toward
our demise, but what is best for us.
Romans chapter 8 28 says, "And we know
that all things work together for good
to those who love God, to those who are
the called according to his purpose."
>> Amen. Looking to God for guidance
centers our identity in him. If
something is allowed back into my life
or into your life, it is God who has
made that choice for us. Not our
feelings, not our emotions or impulses,
not even the thing or person who is
coming back into our space. For
reference, consider the story of Hosea
and Goomer. for an extreme example of
God deciding what might seem humanly
like the worst possible option we could
choose. But God had a purpose beyond
human comprehension.
Now, this story is not a blueprint for
everyone, but it just shows how we ought
to submit to God's wisdom and sovereign
authority in these types of matters.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you. you know, when
when you guys are all answering these
questions, I'm always looking for
something that just really speaks to me.
And you know, for me, I love that you
said, "God is a specialist in baggage
sorting."
>> Oh, yes.
>> So, I appreciated that. Thank you so
much, uh, Fotini. So, we're going to
come to you and this question comes from
Harvey uh from British Columbia sends an
email and they ask, "I have been a
greeter in my church for many years and
consider myself to be a self-appointed
jester. As a greeter, I often see people
who look sad, and I've made it my goal
to try to bring a smile or even a little
chuckle to their lives. Should I instead
be more quiet and simply wish them a
happy Sabbath?
>> Well, Harvey, in short, no.
>> Do not simply be quiet and wish them a
happy Sabbath, but I'll also explain
why.
>> Well, greeters play an exceptionally
important role in the church because
they represent the first first face of
fellowship, right? We have the open door
policy of the church where everybody is
welcome and regardless if it's your
first time at church or if you're a
longtime member, the first person you
actually see is the greeter. And
biblically speaking, greetings play a
very important role. And we can see this
for example in Paul's epistles where he
takes three to sometimes seven verses to
just open up the letter with greetings
where he addresses practical issues um
but also pri provides hope for the
people reading it through the person of
Jesus Christ. And now aligning that with
the question,
the role of the greeter is very similar
that you stand on the front lines and
you meet people where they're at when
they come to church. Now, you mentioned
that sometimes they have a sad face. At
that point, I have to say, well, praise
the Lord. They had enough oomph to come
to church to begin with, depending on
how their week went. That may be the
crowning achievement, making it to the
building. And what a blessing it would
be to find someone there to cheer them
up. So I really appreciate that and you
personally that you've taken that
stance. However, let's look at the some
Bible verses that can really show how we
can shine for Jesus in showing the joy
that we receive from him. If we just
take Psalm 118:24 to heart, this is the
day that the Lord has made. I will
rejoice and be glad in it. Well, what
does rejoicing really look like? And we
can read an example of that from John
15:11 where Jesus speaks of the joy that
originates from a relationship with him.
He says, "These things I have spoken to
you that my joy may remain in you and
that your joy may remain full." Because
in 2 Corinthians 1:es 3-4, we read about
a God who comforts us, but we are also
to comfort others with that same comfort
that we receive through him. And when we
come to those positions where we we have
the opportunity to shine in a ministry
such as greeting, how beautiful it is to
bring that joy to others, to be that
bright light in somebody's life. Because
in Zephaniah 3:17, we read so many
wonderful promises of the Lord. The Lord
your God is in your midst, particularly
in church and on the Sabbath. The mighty
one will save. He will rejoice over you
with gladness. He will quiet you with
his love. and he will sing over you and
he and he will rejoice over you with
singing reminding people of verses such
as these of promises of even how God
walks through us through the valley of
the shadow of death that God is with us
we shall fear no evil sometimes a
reminder like that can play such an
important role in somebody's disposition
depending on how their week has gone and
but sharing that true joy that comes
through your fellowship with Jesus
Christ is a beautiful way to be a bright
spot in someone's life and pointing them
to him who is the light of the world.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. I really appreciate, you know, the
the question that Harvey asked because
none of us here are perfect and I've had
those days showing up to to church and,
you know, world has gotten you and
everything that week just seemed to go
wrong, but then you come to church like
you said, you you made it.
>> Uh and praise the Lord, you made it. And
the fact that you know somebody was
there and take has that kind of
disposition where they want to make you
happy. They want you to feel welcome
that can change your entire Sabbath from
feeling dark and gloomy to you know God
is with me. Jesus is with me and we're
going to have a blessed Sabbath. So I
really appreciate your answer and the
question here too.
>> Amen.
>> All right, Pastor Denzy, we're going to
come to you. This is from Dale in South
Carolina, and they text this question in
and ask, "Where can I find reliable
information showing that the so-called
lost or omitted books of the Bible were
not actually lost or removed?"
>> That's a good question.
>> You know, it's interesting uh when you
use the word reliable information. I
would have to say reliable information
we find in the Bible.
So the question is
these ideas of lost books or omitted
books the I don't know how many years
for for how many years books that are
claimed to be lost have been been
published by people. So let's go to the
Bible because the Bible really mentions
some books that are not included in the
Bible cannon and this is reliable
information in the Bible. So in numbers
21:14 we have the following words.
Wherefore it is said in the book of the
wars of the Lord what he did in the Red
Sea and in the brooks of Arnon. So this
uh book of the wars of the Lord we don't
have it. We don't have access to it. Uh
look at Joshua 10:13. It says and the
sun stood still and the moon stayed
until the people had avenged themselves
upon their enemies. Is this written is
is not this written in the book of
Jasher? So the son stood still in the
midst of heaven and hasted not to go
down about a whole day. 2 Samuel 1 17
and 18. And David lamented with this
lamentation over Saul and over Jonathan
his son. Also he ba them teach the
children of Judah the use of the bow.
Behold it is written in the book of
Jasher. How about first Kings 11:41? and
the rest of the acts of Solomon and all
that he did and his wisdom are they not
written in the book of the acts of
Solomon. So these three books, we don't
have access to them. They are not
they're missing, let's say. But please
understand that God has protected the
Holy Scriptures so that we have in the
Holy Scriptures all that you need to
understand the plan of salvation to
understand the signs and the preparation
we need to be ready for the soon return
of our Lord and Savior. Please don't go
looking for lost books of the Bible,
reading those so-called lo book books of
the Bible because all that you need is
contained in the holy scriptures. And so
do not be do not go on a what is a wild
goose chase some people call them to try
to find these books and read them.
Perhaps some of them may contain
information about history but we cannot
call it's interesting too we cannot call
them let's say uh books of the Bible
because the books of the Bible are in
the Bible you see and so please
understand that God has taken care of
the scriptures and God has guided his
people to know which books should be
included and which books should not.
Having said that, I have to say the
Catholic Church has some books, seven of
them that are considered apocryphal,
which means that they are of doubtful
origin or doubtful inspiration. And the
Protestant believers do not look at
these books as inspired. That's why
they're not in the Protestant holy
scriptures. Amen. Amen. You know, I like
how you mentioned about going down uh
rabbit holes because when you start to
go dive into some of these things, you
know, the enemy will use that to
distract us from what God's word is
actually saying and to take us down
paths that we don't need to be studying
and be more focused on his word rather
trying to find these lost books and
yeah, going down rabbit holes. I know at
one point I found myself doing that a
little bit. So, so I'm glad you
mentioned that. Thank you. All right. Uh
Derell, we're going to come to you and
this question is from Nancy in
Tennessee. She texts this question and
Nancy asks, "When a Christian has a
loving heart but resists studying
biblical truth and clings to tradition,
how can they be helped to see what the
Bible really says?"
Thank you, Nancy, for your question. And
there's a saying that says, "A man
convinced against his will is of the
same opinion." Still, unfortunately,
there is nothing that we can do to force
someone to see things from our
perspective or even from God's
perspective. One of the greatest
blessings about the gospel is that the
acceptance of it is based upon the
willing submission of that individual to
the divine authority of Christ at that
very moment. That means that Christ can
present us uh one truth today which we
accept and yet still present us greater
truth tomorrow that may cause us to have
a bit of hesitation because of our own
heart issues. And sometimes we may even
wholeheartedly reject reject certain
truths because we have erected our own
truth so high up in place of God's
truth. Jesus spoke of this when he
talked about men teaching for as
doctrines the commandments of men
instead of of God.
And so each to each individual is given
time and capacity to choose to accept
the light presented to them from God's
word. The song in his time comes to my
mind when we consider how God knows just
how to bring out the best outcome in
people even when for the longest while
it seems like there may be no hope of
them re receiving the light. So with
that said as you stated there is
certainly something we can do tactfully
to help to bring truth uh to those who
need to hear it. In fact, there is a
foolproof method of presenting the tr
truths of God to others that is the most
likely to achieve the intended result of
seeing that person accept truth they
would normally have rejected. That
method is actually Christ's method of
winning souls. Often we become focused
on drawing people to truth when in
reality we are seeking to point them to
Christ.
Note that it is Christ who is the truth
according to John 14:6. And it is Christ
who does the drawing to himself
according to John 12:32.
Our responsibility is found in 2 Timothy
verse 4:2
that says, "Preach the word, be ready in
season and out of season, convince,
rebuke, exhort with all longsuffering
and teaching." Notice the element of
longsuffering implies the necessity of
possessing certain essential qualities
of Christ, namely the fruit of the
spirit. What I love is the fact that the
fruit of the spirit is the key to, as
you say, get someone to awaken to the to
what the Bible really says. When we
begin by asking God for a love for the
person we see in error, we will come to
that person as one who desires what is
good and best for them. One of the
greatest things we can do is pray,
"Lord, please hide me. Get me out of the
way. Use me as a vessel filled by your
spirit and help me to love this person
and seek to win them with the patience
of Christ and with the trust that Christ
who promised to draw them to himself and
to draw them to his truth will do it in
his perfect timing."
>> Amen. Amen. What came to my mind when
you were saying that was I don't know
maybe some of you have heard this phrase
before but because you touched on Christ
method people don't care what you know
until they know that you care.
>> Amen.
>> And that's kind of what you were
touching on there. So I really
appreciate that. Thank you.
>> All right, Foutini, we're going to come
to you. And this question comes from
Tracy. She sends an email
>> and she asks, "What exactly did God
create on the first day? Also, why did
he divide the day from the night and
create day and night twice? once on day
one and once on day four.
>> Well, let's look at that, Tracy. In
Genesis 1:2, we read that darkness was
on the face of the deep. And then in
verse three, we hear God saying, "Let
there be light." And God divided the
light from the darkness. Let's look at
that word divided for a moment. The
Hebrew word used here is more in a sense
of distinguishing between. When we
compare that to another more well-known
dividing or parting that happened in
scripture when Moses parted the Red Sea,
of course, but then later on it reads
that God caused the waters to see or the
sea to go back and the waters were
divided. The divided using used there
means that there was Red Sea on this end
and there was Red Sea on the other side.
That's not the same dividing that's
happening between light and darkness.
There is very clear distinction
happening in this case. And as we move
on, we can read what happened after God
divided the light from the darkness. He
called the light day with a capital D
and he called the night and he called
the darkness night with a capital N. He
named them with proper nouns. Proper
nouns represent specific places among
other things. And so here we have a
distinction of God's transparent
righteousness being set up from the
foundation of the world and separated
distinctly from the darkness which he
called night which is all the bad stuff
that God is not for lack of a better
term and lack of time. And we see that
throughout scripture God is always
dividing his children from the uh
idolatrous nations always separating the
holy from the profane. And so the same
is happening here. And we'll notice a
cadence of spiritual physical spiritual
in this in this time frame. And that was
the first spiritual component.
Let's read what the light or the day
represents in scripture. 1 John 15. This
is the message that we have heard from
him and declare to you that God is light
and in him is no darkness at all. So now
what happened afterward is that God said
let there be lights in the firmament of
the heavens to divide the day from the
night. This is where the day from the
night is actually being divided for the
first time with a very physical presence
of the sun, the moon and the stars. And
scripture says it is for times and
seasons so that we can one understand
prophecy better but also for our
circadian rhythm and the cadence of
time.
There's another thing that happens later
on when we read again that the greater
light was set there to rule or was given
authority over the day and the lesser
light was given rule over the night
again to divide the light from the
darkness not to divide the night from
the day that happened once. So here we
have the spiritual significance again
and we can read about the greater light
in John 8:12. Then Jesus spoke to them
saying again I am the light of the
world. I am the greater light. But even
when we walk in spiritual darkness, God
has still left us a light to look up to.
And when we take this concept and apply
it to the end of the book, the book of
Revelation, we see that spiritual
component magnified in Revelation 21:23,
speaking of the new Jerusalem. The city
had no need of the sun or the moon to
shine in it. Right? Because why? The
glory of God will illuminate it and the
lamb is its light.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Fini. Well, for
the sake of time, I'm just going to jump
right to you, Pastor Denzy.
>> Uh, so this question comes from Anthony
in Ohio. He texts this question and he
asks, "According to Mark 12:25, there
won't be marriage after the
resurrection, but according to Isaiah
65:23,
people will have children on the new
earth. If there's no marriage, how are
people going to have children?"
Thank you so much. Uh yes in the book of
Mark and in the book of Isaiah it may
seem to be a contradiction to some
people but when you go to the book of
Isaiah please understand uh that in
verse in chapter 65 it is being uh you
see a description there of how it would
have been for the people of Israel as
God's chosen people if they obey the
commandments and follow the Lord with
all their hearts. God was going to
apparently bring them blessings that
appear to be blessings similar to what
we will experience in heavens made new.
The new earth and evil do no longer
exist. But there are also elements that
lets us know that they are talking about
time on the earth. Let's go to Isaiah 65
beginning verse 17 to see these things.
For behold, I create new heavens and a
new earth, and the former shall not be
remembered or come to mine. This is the
new earth, heavens made new. But it
says, "But be glad and rejoice forever
in what I create. For behold, I create
Jerusalem as a rejoicing and her people
a joy. I will rejoice in Jerusalem and
joy in my people. The voice of weeping
shall no longer be heard in her, nor the
voice of crying." It appears to be
talking about heaven when sin does not
exist. But now in verse 20, no more
shall an infant from there live but a
few days, nor an old man who has not
fulfilled his days. For the child shall
die 100 years old, but the sinner being
100 years old shall be accursed. So this
is not talking about heaven when sin is
no longer existing. So the people of
Israel were going to enjoy some of the
benefits. God was going to take diseases
away from them and they would be
protected from their enemies. Let's
continue reading. They shall build
houses and inhabit them. They shall
plant vineyards and eat their fruit.
They shall not build and another
inhabit. Why? Because the Lord is
protecting them. Will not allow the
enemy to overtake them. They shall not
plant and another eat. For as the days
of a tree, so shall the days of my
people and my elect shall my elect shall
long enjoy the work of their hands. They
shall not labor in vain, nor bring forth
children for trouble, for they shall be
descendants of the blessed of the Lord
and their offsprings with them. So read
Deuteronomy chapter 7 to see some of the
benefits the Lord was promising to them,
including taking away diseases and
things like that. So this is a a
temporary situation that God was going
to bring to the people of Israel. So
some of the elements are there do talk
about uh how it will be when sin is no
longer, but this is seems to be a
special blessing for the people of
Israel. had they been faithful.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, that was a excellent
answer and an excellent question. Thank
you for sending that in. Now, uh we just
have a few moments here, so we're just
going to take a quick break, let you
know how you can send in your questions,
and we'll be right back. If you're
enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A, then tell
your friends. Each Monday, we'll bring
you a fresh program answering the Bible
questions you send us using God's holy
word to shed light on those texts that
seem difficult to understand. To have
your questions answered on a future
program, just email them to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bible qa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch 3ABN Bible Q&A
for answers from God's word.
All right, Thorabian family, welcome
back. Well, we just have a few moments
here, so I'm just going to open up the
table for some closing comments. Drell,
would you like anything that you need to
add or want to add?
>> Uh, sure. uh regarding the last question
that I had um about letting something
back into your life. I know what it's
like to uh be kind of estranged from,
you know, family members and um and so
so those are some of the the more
serious um things that we we are have
reservations of letting back into our
lives. But I I really encourage you to
to put it into God's hands because he
knows how to sort out all the
differences that we may have. And yes,
they may not be may not have the same
influence in your life after the fact,
but God knows best.
>> Amen.
>> Fini.
>> Amen. Just to piggyback off of that,
what a blessing that was for me as well,
hearing your answers. It's so wonderful
to be here to learn and to grow, not
only to respond to answers, but also to
grow spiritually as well.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, concerning the lost
books of the Bible, some people say
there's one that's been mentioned, the
Book of Enoch, the Gospel of Thomas, the
Gospel of Mary. These are books not
considered inspired by God's people. So,
don't go off into like a wild goose
chase. The lost books of the Bible are
mentioned in the Bible. And for some
reason, God did not allow these to come
into the Bible.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Pastor Denzy.
Thank you, Foutini. Thank you, Drell. It
was a pleasure to hear all the questions
and answers and thank you for being with
us. And I just want to leave you with
this and this comes from Numbers chapter
6. The Lord bless you and keep you. The
Lord make his face shine upon you and be
gracious to you. The Lord lift up his
countenance upon you and give you peace.
Until next time, may God be with you.